I wouldn't have had a career in the 80s
and 90s are you kidding talking about
why and purpose I would have been
laughed out of you big purpose on like
hippie dippy stuff I I joke that you
know it's embarrassing that I have a
career I took a trust in cooperation
there should be no demand but the fact
that there is and people want to talk
about this and learn about this the fact
that it's a public conversation I think
a rejection of the 80s and 90s form of
capitalism the you know where we over
indexed on rugged individualism and
shareholder Supremacy and profit before
people
um and profit before purpose
um I you know gives me hope that even
though it's a bumpy road and we haven't
figured out what it'll look like I think
we're trending in the right direction
and and we're having those conversations
and the companies that are doing that
are the companies that we're
highlighting and wanting to work for so
I'm very optimistic